it's time for ej's veto
presented by no one unsullied by
sponsorship
since uh thank you dr o'neill what what
are you disgusted about
what exactly phil mickelson fired me
what exactly tom brady did
for me to get lose my position oh you
stink
[Music]
we the champ you have to beat the champ
you want to go out on top man
check it out and you did y'all you know
what y'all keep messing with me
i'm gonna show up out there in montana
with bruce kepka
keep it up hey do you want trucks are
you familiar with danny rouye
danny rouye yeah uh not by name
sports talk radio host in dc 106.7 the
fan
uh does a show with grant paulsen he's
also a comedian
yeah and you know and he and he can do
some impressions
one in particular which i think you will
find
uh you saw scary have you seen this i
don't think i
went super viral this is this is
everybody here's danny
this the first half analysis the half of
basketball was played that's not the
whole game
that's half the game damon lillard he
did a step back
but he stepped forward and then he moved
back
he went back about 25 feet that's
probably that travel
but they're not gonna call it michael uh
junior porter
he made a bunch of shots nicola yoka
uh joe kitch joe kitchen he made he he's
tall
and nicola yerkitch or joker jimmy and
joe jerkich
uh didn't found nobody that was
something that's a good half of
basketball
between portland and cleveland back to
you ernie
i've heard a lot of guys do you i i
don't know if anybody's been better than
that
that's pretty good right there danny
routier rouyet
was pretty good too [ __ ] that was
pretty good man
very talented dude cali on those oh
frank's the best yeah frank is my man
but this was this was very exciting he's
in dc
yeah he is so next time 106.7 the fan
calls you for an interview
i'm just letting you know but as we're
not going to dc anytime soon
i've seen them guys play i i think
that's a wrap for inside the nba
great impersonation by kia